make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with
uh swords of x and in this video we're
focusing on the return
of mad gym jaspers yes we
are but before we get into that we are
going to pick up with a couple little
fun things that happen here a couple
little small things the first part of
this focuses on x-men issue number 14
but this is really just exposition and
the reality is we don't
really learn a lot that we didn't
already know before but there are a
couple things that we do pick up here
the first of these things really comes
with the twilight sword and the twilight
sword of course as it's being wielded by
apocalypse's wife
genesis is a weapon that's part of the
ten of swords or exosaurus event right
it's one of the things that the forces
of morocco
had to gather in order to fight against
the forces of krakowa but as i was
reading this and that's yesterday was
basically kind of retelling this origin
of mutant kind at least as it existed on
okara which is originally what kercoa
and oracle were before they were split
in two we of course get the same
expedition that we always did right the
twilight sword of the enemy
tore the world asunder and what was one
became two and i started thinking about
this right now it says after that
happened that all the enemies of ammon
basically poured into the world like
poured into the main marvel universe
right so they came from this other place
right just this this kind of you know
other other dimension and it led to
you know it led to them invading the
world and seeking to capture it for the
most part now of course as a result of
that you saw two things happening you
saw apocalypse
leading the mutant population against
the forces of ammon
and then you saw what was basically the
the white sword right so this
you know external this immortal mutant
who basically has the ability to
resurrect you know him and his 100
soldiers
every single morning to kind of fight
the fight again that they went through
the portal alongside with a
alongside apocalypse's wife and the
various mutants who were there for the
purpose of trying to fight these forces
back
right now of course we know that just by
virtue of the stories that we read
that the promise apocalypse made to his
wife is he would prepare the world as a
place that could hold itself against the
forces of ameth which is why he's always
maintained this kind of
survival of the fittest mentality right
this is something that you can find in
our video that we did
on the new origin of apocalypse in our
x-men playlist where you can get totally
caught up on the the exodus swords event
by the ten of swords event but the more
i thought about this and this is what's
so cool the more i thought about this
was specifically the twilight sword of
the enemy and how his forces how the the
forces you know once this twilight
once the twilight sword emerged that the
enemy basically escaped that like all
these forces came pouring out if i'm a
betting man
i think that's certain and here's a
reason why if you go back and you look
at journey into mystery number 97
from way back in the day what you had
was a story whereby odin ended up facing
off against certain and this led to
surter being
locked inside the earth now at some
future point in time and we're not
really told when
certain managed to get out right sort of
escaped and then just kind of showed up
somewhere along the line this was back
in the day when marvel wouldn't
necessarily provide these clear-cut
explanations in terms of how
a leads into b instead it was just you
get the end of a and then you're into b
and then we don't you don't really get a
lot of connecting of the dots that's
what made chris claremont style of
writing so landmark was because of the
fact that he did that
for 17 years right it was it was a huge
thing to kind of keep the story
narrative going and everything tied into
everything else
but if certain managed to escape earth
then this was this would explain the
earth kind of you know this land
cracking in two right it just happened
to be where sort of emerged from but the
reason why i say him and nobody else is
because as you guys know
the main weapon of sir is a twilight
sword and so it makes perfect sense that
certain basically emerged with a
twilight sword and then went and did his
thing right and then from there you know
all these enemy forces came pouring out
and who in the heck knows where it was
that they came from
right but the long and short of this is
that with that bit of an explanation
being offered there that genesis has
kind of emerged here as a person who is
in effect
the leader of of seemingly everybody
right now initially she donned the
golden helm of annihilation which we
talked about before
because it was what would allow her to
control the forces of ammon
and again we're not really given a lot
of indication here what what she really
points here is this notion that the
forces of ammons are effectively
leaderless
and that the individual who wields the
golden helm is the person who can
control them and so it stands to reason
that if certain was locked inside earth
by odin and sirder basically formed this
private army for himself and the forces
of amith and then somewhere along the
line soda escaped that he would just
leave them all behind
and so without any real leader the
individual who dons the golden helm
basically takes over that role the
problem with this is that the golden
helm cannot be controlled and so just
because you put it on and just because
the golden helm will allow you to
control the forces of ameth does not
mean you can control the golden helm and
that's what she says
that the will of the golden helm is now
her will and the golden helm wanted to
get into krakowa and so
she does as well and that's why she's
basically a villain here because her
stance is we're going to end up fighting
each other to the death
and her whole goal is to win the contest
or at least for for oracle to win the
contest so they can invade krakowa so
that's the whole motivation behind her
character and that's how i think certain
ties
into all this stuff but for the the the
goody stuff here right the the good
little tidbit here
this is when we pick up with jim
jasper's because i feel like that's what
you guys
really want to see right you guys really
really really want to see this so here's
a cool thing that happens here
right off the bat we pick up with the
crooked market and you've got jim
jasper's right and he's basically
telling his guys like be super quick
right like saturnine will not tolerate
us missing so much as a single grain of
salt right the crooked market are the
ones who are supplying the various foods
and things like that for this great big
huge feast and this feast is being held
in honor of the various people who are
here that are fighting now
this is not uncommon and in fact this is
really jonathan hickman borrowing from
days gone by in older years it was
common that when you had a war or
conflict going on
between two territories it was designed
to settle a dispute and the conflict was
being held in the location of
a non-partisan third party that third
party would actually honor
both groups and basically bring forth
their champions and then they would all
feast
knowing full well they were probably
going to kill each other in the morning
but that was just kind of the way that
things were done back then right there
was a lot of emphasis put on decorum and
really the ceremonial aspect of what it
meant to get involved in a conflict now
understand
there's no love loss here just because
they're all sharing dinner here does not
mean they're going to be good friends
you know you even have things like like
you've got cypher who's out there kind
of minding his own business you've got
storm who looks like she's kind of
flirting with anubis it looks like
anubis anyway and then of course
you also have wolverine who's just kind
of being standoffish because it's
wolverine and that's what he does right
he's just a standoffish guy but the
doors officially open
the banners basically fall in the hall
and then it's everybody make your way in
and as they get in here
it's actually an incredible sight to
behold and that was one of the things
about saturday right she was nothing if
not somebody who liked everyone to know
just how good she had it but you end up
getting this really cool situation where
we're basically introduced to jasper's
right where jasper's is officially
recognized and declared here and it's
like all of this
is brought to us by jim jasper's of the
crooked market right we also get
lady roma of the fae you get vesperade
the colony queen of the the hothive or
the hot hive whatever you want to call
it
famine who's basically the region of the
former kingdom of dryador
and then jim jasper's kind of comments
and says well you may not be welcome
into dryador but you are always welcome
to my crooked market right if you come
there you can find virtually anything
that you want but here's the funny thing
about this
right here's so here's what's so crazy
about this and it's something super easy
to overlook here jim jasper's is acting
incredibly casual here he's like yeah i
mean come to the crooked market if you
have to but let's not be
naive about this guy jim jaspers is a
guy who was so powerful that his
alternate reality counterpart was a
threat to the entire multiverse they had
to kill his universe they had to wipe
his universe out in order to save the
multiverse and he was still
weaker than this version of jim jasper's
here this guy is a multiversal force
that's all the sky is right this guy
is just death incarnate there are very
few things very precious few things that
could stand in the face of jim jasper's
now this guy is
ridiculously overpowered now how his
power compares to saturnine
i'm not really sure and i would really
say just pomp circumstance and just
being being polite here is the only
thing that's keeping jim jasper's from
just being like you know what i'm bored
let's turn everybody into cupcakes and
then
stomp on him right i feel like that's
the only thing that's stopping him from
doing that or just
waving his hand and turning everybody
into blobs of goo and that's the end of
them
no one here could stop jim jasper's if
he got bored and decided to kill
everybody that's kind of what i'm
telling you here right that's how
powerful this guy is
that's how powerful jim jaspers is and
that's why it's so
incredibly exciting to see him back
because i feel like things are gonna pop
off in this place now the other funny
thing that happens here is you've got
ryan braddock right and brian braddock
is here just kind of you know doing his
thing and just sort of chilling out and
wolverine walks up on him and he's like
look man you had an opportunity to
basically stop all this right like when
saturday took you to her took her to her
bed chambers and you guys were gonna do
you know you guys were gonna do the
thing you know you're gonna you're gonna
knock boots like you could have just
gone through with it
right and then like none of this would
have happened in the first place you
know he's like well i'm a married man
he's like well here's the thing though
man like you know if you really cared
about all of us you would have taken one
for the team
it's what i would have done you know i
would have taken one for the team and
just called it a day it's kind of a
funny little thing
obviously no respectable man would do
that but you know wolverine
is not really a respectable guy right
and so what he really does here is he
kind of looks at brian braddock
as the reason for this whole problem
he's like you know i'm not really going
to be watching anybody out there who's
most likely going to die instead
i'm going to be watching you i'm going
to be keeping my eye on you and i'm
going to know that with all the people
who die
from kokoa if any end up dying tomorrow
at all they will all have died because
of you now the other part of this comes
with gorgon and iliana rasputin now
gorgon is a guy that we haven't really
covered
too much in marvel comics in fact i
think the only time we really offered
any measure of explanation on him was
during the events of secret empire
because he was part of the hydra inner
circle and so we could do with a bear a
bit of explanation here the idea behind
gorgon's powers and the reason why he
wears the mask the way he does
is because he essentially has the powers
of medusa if he were to take his mask
off anywhere to look at you you would
turn to stone and so he wears that mask
in order to prevent that from happening
the problem with this
is it takes away his eyesight and so
gorgon is a guy who
is by all standards of measurement blind
even if only because he chooses to be
but he's also probably one of the best
fighters
in all of marvel comics when i say all
of marvel comics i mean all of marvel
comics like this guy
could give almost anybody a run for
their money and it doesn't really matter
who it is
the other part of this is that with him
and magic sizing up everybody here
you've also got
iska now iska as a lot of you guys if
you may recall she's a person whose
mutant power
is that she can't lose and so if for
example she you know she's part of this
whole great big huge tournament and her
mutant power
you know because she can't lose is that
things going the way they are it's
obvious
the forces of gracoa are going to win
should turn against the forces of
morocco
it's just the nature of her powers now
what marvel doesn't really explain here
and this is the problem you have with a
power that's this ambiguous is it
passive or is it active when it comes to
powers in marvel comics you have active
and passive
powers and even in dc it works the exact
same way so something like
superman's frost breath that's an act of
power right he actually has to blow
frost breath at somebody but something
like wolverine's healing factor is a
passive power he doesn't have to do
anything it just
automatically happens and so we don't
know if that's the case with her
or if it's active or is passive we don't
really know we don't know if like
you know she allies with with cricoid
i'm sorry with the rocco because she's
foreseen that a rocko is going to win
we don't know if she allies with gracoa
or if she ends up turning against the
rocko and allies with cocoa because her
mutant power tells her krakow is going
to win we don't really know
marvel hasn't really taken the time to
explain it it may be one of these things
where hickman kind of gives us this bit
of a tease and we don't find out how our
powers work for
100 issues right that's entirely
possible but the cool thing about this
is that because they're aware of iska's
ability the question
is which side does she favor does she
favor her left side her right side how
deep do her powers go
right that's the question of gorgon and
magic and so what they end up doing is
basically kind of you know approaching
her
offering a bit of small talk obviously
giving her a little bit of a hard time
and then as a test they drop their
glasses at the same time
and because she's ambidextrous she
catches them both and doesn't drop one
drop of it and so it's like okay
like of course she's ambidextrous if she
can't lose she has all the skills she
needs to succeed
and so she doesn't really favor her left
or her right side in fighting and so she
doesn't really have an infinitive
weakness
in terms of her fighting style in turn
she pulls the same stunt on
on magic and gorgon and then magic opens
a portal that caused them to fall back
through and then of course it's like you
know we caught them
so again it's one of these cool things
where these foes these various fighters
are learning a lot about each other
because understand
this is the first time all of them are
meeting each other which is kind of it
was a really really cool moment here
it's the first time that they're all
meeting each other and so when you have
this bit of a discussion here you
actually end up having a
having storm who approaches the horseman
death and the two of them all start
talking you know two of them kind of
have this great big huge conversation
now there is a bit of a tease and so far
as maybe storm is kind of romantically
attracted to him maybe it's this kind of
devil may care or a bit of a mystery or
intrigue but one thing to understand
about storm she's not some wide-eyed
girl who just stepped out into the world
she's not naive right she's not a naive
person and so while she is kind of
entertaining this possibility that there
could be a romance between her
and the horseman death she basically
ends it fast right and she's like i've
danced with your kind before and i was
curious what kind of person you were
because i'm gonna be fighting you and
now that i know what kind of person you
are i know that one you're an honorable
and respectable person but two i know
that i wouldn't really have any qualms
with killing you and so from there
he kind of picks up with saturnine
speaking directly with with wolverine
right and wolverine
is really just kind of pissed right he's
just walking around like a big grump
like he usually does but a little
grumpier than normal and saturn
kind of asks him like you know i know
when a mind is burdened what's on what's
on your mind right what are you thinking
and at the end of the day like
he kind of holds off in having a
conversation but she kind of pushes and
prods and he says fine right
it doesn't have to be like this all you
have to do is take whatever
it is that you want and then we can end
this here there's no need for some great
big ceremony
none of this is a necessity you're
playing a game you're being awfully
cavalier with
all of our lives for your own
entertainment now for saturnine's part
she's in her rights to do this right the
conflict between gracoa and the conflict
between a rocko happened to come up on
her doorstep and then that's the nature
of the beast when two people are
fighting and their fight takes them into
somebody's house they don't get to
dictate how the person who owns that
house
allows them to fight they fall under the
rules of the person inside that house
right a man doesn't walk into another
man's home
and start telling him what's what it's
just the way it is right and so because
their conflict led to them at this point
she's the one that gets to call and gets
to call the rules right so that's just
kind of the way that goes
and the response she really gives here
is i said exactly what i meant right
death is the great change everything
dies right one of you guys are going to
die here and everything's going to
change after
if anything i'm just curious what it is
that's going to happen and the response
of wolverine is
those are some famous last words his
claws and stabbed saturnine with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob cork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
do
[Music]
you